we told you a few minutes ago a bill to
ensure funding for the healthcare of
9/11 first responders is being blocked
in the Senate by two Republican senators
Rand Paul and Mike Lee Senator Paul took
to the floor today saying the spending
needs to be offset by cuts elsewhere
we're going to get reaction now from Jon
Stewart comedian activist he's been a
leading advocate for this fund and one
of the first responders John feel
gentlemen thanks for being here
mr. field thanks for your service I just
want to get your reaction first to this
news today and kind of what you're
thinking well thank you for having us
and you guys have been generous with
your time at Fox telling our story so
thank you listen we're not surprised by
senator Lee and Paul this is their mo we
kind of had an idea that this would
happen but if you watch yesterday when
South Dakota Majority Whip tuned he did
a rule 14 unanimous consent before
Senator Gillibrand
did her unanimous consent and Mitch
McConnell he gave us his word and he's
been sincere about that and we're
confident when the bill goes on the
floor for straight up-and-down vote
senator Lee and Senator Paul are going
to lose and any amendment they try to
make you know we have 73 co-sponsors we
have a two-thirds majority and I don't
think anything they have to offer holds
water but you know let's let's get to
you know Rand Paul got 580 thousand
dollars for broken ribs we get 250
thousand dollars for cancer
Tom Wilson who had tongue removed and
his neck reconstructed gets $250,000
he'll probably die from cancer Luis
Alvarez died from cancer he got $250,000
so I think both the des Senate is the
people from the state of Kentucky and
the people from the state of Utah
deserve better much better and I think
they lack humanity yeah this is what the
Washington Post says about this fund
this is the fund provides money to those
who've contracted diseases that have
been linked to exposure to toxic debris
in the aftermath of September 11th
attacks which we knew under current law
the fund is scheduled to stop taking
claims in December 2020 the new
legislation would extend the program for
seven decades at an estimated cost of
10.2 billion for the first decade here's
how Senator Paul said that on the floor
today any new spending that we are
approaching any new program that's going
to have the longevity of 7080 years
should be offset by cutting spending
that's less valuable we need to at the
very least have this debate I will be
offering up an amendment if spill should
come to the floor
but until then I will object John Stuart
your reaction it's it's it's absolutely
outrageous and you'll pardon me if I'm
not impressed in any way by Rand Paul's
fiscal responsibility virtue signaling
Rand Paul presented tissue-paper
avoidance of the 1.5 trillion dollar tax
cut that added hundreds of billions of
dollars to our deficit and now he stands
up at the last minute after 15 years of
blood sweat and tears from the 9/11
community to say that it's all over now
now we're going to balance the budget on
the backs of the 9/11 first responder
community Brett this is about what kind
of society we have at some point we have
to stand up for the people who have
always stood up for us and at this
moment in time maybe cannot stand up for
themselves due to their illnesses and
their injuries and what Rand Paul did
today on the Senate was outrageous he is
a guy that put us in hundreds of
billions of dollars of debt he was the
51st vote on that cut and now he's going
to tell us that a billion dollars a year
over 10 years is just too much for us to
handle you know there's some things that
they have no trouble putting on the
credit card
but somehow when it comes to the 9/11
first responder community the cops the
firefighters the construction workers
the volunteers the survivors all of a
sudden man we got to go through this
this program has already been running
for five years no fraud it was testified
when we went in front of Congress the
special paymaster testified no fraud no
waste no abuse Mike Lee we met in his
office five years ago he looked us in
the eye he looked ray Pfeiffer in the
eye who unfortunately is no longer
thus and said he was going to look into
it he is the reason that we've had to go
back again for this new one and now he
wants to put another cap on it that's
going to make John feel and all these
other tenacious yet ill first responders
dragged themselves back to Washington to
put their hats in their hands and beg
for something that this country should
have done 14 years ago you know we asked
an abomination we asked both senators
for a statement senators Paul senator
Paul's office sent a statement saying
Senator Paul is not blocking anything
he's simply seeking to pay for it as
with any bill Senator Paul always
believes it needs to be paid for Senator
Paul is simply offering an amendment
which other senators support to pay for
this legislation obviously after all you
said here and attending the funeral of
your colleague Luis Alvarez John feel
that's not where you are now listen um
Senator Paul and Senator Lee are
opportunities they're bottom-feeders and
any statement that they come out with is
doesn't hold water with me you can't
cherry pick and choose when you want to
be a conservative fiscal hawk that's
that's just insulting to our Angele
intelligence and shame on them they lack
humanity they lack leadership and they
just do this because listen Ted Cruz
Rand Paul Mike Lee even their own
colleagues don't like them we don't like
them and when we get this bill passed
then we beat them again and we're gonna
walk out and we're gonna hold our chins
up high and I'll chest out and we're
gonna say we beat Rand Paul and Mike Lee
you know we met Mike Lee a couple months
ago his staff they promised they swore
up and down that they were not gonna get
in the way of this Mike Lee you're a
lawyer but the other thing to Bret is to
remember at what point this is either
necessary or it's not and everybody
agrees that it's necessary so we're
either doing this over thought there's
either a need or it's not your budgetary
priorities are either moved by a moral
compass or they're not and this is an
outrageous place for them to take it
stand and cause once again pain and
heartache and suffering within a
community that has felt so much of that
over these past
few years and is going to be suffering
more and Brett you know this is Brett
this is what people see has a major
defeat today's a minor setback and it's
just gonna propel us to a bigger win and
we're confident that after meeting with
Mitch McConnell that he's kept his word
and he's working diligently to get this
bill on the floor for a straight
up-and-down vote and that's what we
always wanted the unanimous consent was
easy but we want a straight up-and-down
vote because we didn't get it in 2010 we
didn't get it in 2015 and we want to
walk out watching the fruition of all
work come to an end it's the same song
and dance they've given us for 14 years
now this program has proven itself it
has shown itself to be faithful to the
statute it has shown itself to be fair
to the claimant and it has shown itself
to be respectful to the taxpayers and
that's all we can ask of a program but
most importantly it brings just a
moment's peace to a community that has
suffered and continues to suffer Jon
Stewart heroism Jon Stewart and John
feel again Jon feel thank you for your
service we'll continue to follow it
thanks for coming on thank you for
having us